PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Did you
know that 87% of data science
projects never make
it into production?
That's just one out of
every 10 AI projects.
So how do you make sure
your project does not
become one of those 87%?
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this video,
I will walk you through steps
to operationalize your machine
learning workflow
using vertex pipelines,
so your project becomes one
of those 10 successful AI
projects.
We will look at MLOps framework
and vertex AI pipelines, which
helps you break down the
complex multi-step ML
workflow into a pipeline and
ensure that each step runs
in a reproducible, auditable,
cost-effective, and a scalable
way.
In contrast with typical
software systems, which
are traditionally
code-centric, ML systems
involve an intricate
relationship between data,
code, and the models.
Now, data and models
are unique artifacts
with their own
dependencies and pitfalls.
And the joint management
of these three artifacts
is a challenge in
delivering and maintaining
production machine
learning systems.
That is what MLOps is.
MLOps is a culture
and practice that
aims to unify ML system
development and operations
and guide through the
challenges of taking
ML projects from
experimentation to production.
It is just like
DevOps, but for ML.
Hence, MLOps, which handles
managing the life cycle
of data, models, and code.
Let's start with a
high-level MLOps framework.
So the first step
is ML development,
which is inherently
experimental, where
data scientists
and model builders
explore and transform
the data sets,
explore different algorithms,
train many models,
and then compare them.
Then the second step
is continuous training.
Now, production training should
be automatable and repeatable
so it can take new
data or other triggers
and generate new and
better models on demand.
And then the third step
is model deployment,
which is really all about
continuous integration
and continuous delivery.
This involves running
A/B tests, evaluation
of model behavior in production,
and then approving them
for releasing, following a
rigorous, auditable, and even
reversible CIDC process.
And then lastly, it's
continuous monitoring.
You need to continuously
monitor your models
when they are running in
production, because you
want to get a sense of
how they are performing.
This is important to ensure
the quality and business
continuity, but also crucial
for getting high-quality signals
into how to improve a model
for your next iteration.
Model management and
governance is basically
the step that applies
to all of these steps.
It's the entire framework.
We need traceability,
verifiability, and auditability
at each stage of this workflow.
ML pipeline models
this MLOps workflow.
A pipeline is a way
of modeling a workflow
as a set of connected steps.
Each step takes as input the
output of the previous step,
and performs some
additional computations,
and then produces outputs
that can be utilized
by the future components.
Now, here in this
MLOps workflow,
to keep the spirit
of experimentation
in the ML development
phase, we recommend
using the reusable
training pipelines.
And the reason for
reusable pipelines
is because the data scientists
can share components
amongst themselves,
so they don't
have to start with
a blinking cursor
and to rerun and iterate quickly
to create those optimal models.
The output of this step would
be the trained pipeline source
code, which you feed into the
continuous training phase.
The pipeline
generated earlier can
be now treated like a
software application
and is version-controlled and
deployed through CIDC process
as a training
pipeline that can now
be invoked with new
data or parameters
in production as needed.
Now, the output of this step
would be your trained model.
And then the output of
the model deployment
is your live predictions.
And these predictions
can not just
be predictions, but also
logs and other records
of production inferences.
Now, the output of
continuous monitoring--
because you are monitoring
the model continuously,
the output of this
continuous monitoring
is those alerts that
go out to the team,
so that they can continuously
measure and monitor
what the model's performance is
looking like-- is it degrading
or triggering
rollbacks-- and retaining
A/B testing of any
candidate models.
The model management and
governance capabilities,
obviously, as I
said earlier, span
across the entire
framework, including
the features such as, model
registry, model approvals,
and model provenance.
Now, what are vertex pipelines?
Vertex pipelines help you
automate and monitor your ML
systems by orchestrating
this MLOps workflow
in a serverless manner.
They are based on
containers, which
help you make the MLOps process
really portable and scalable.
And the vertex pipelines
store the workflow artifacts
using vertex AI ML metadata,
which makes it easier
to analyze the lineage
of our workflow
and the items that
are being created.
For example, an
ML model's lineage
may include training data, the
hyper-parameters, and the code
that we use to create
the models, which
are critical pieces of
information to understand
the changes in performance or
accuracy of our ML systems.
Now, as you can imagine managing
this metadata by yourself
in an ad hoc manner can be
difficult and time-consuming,
and vertex pipelines
makes it easy to do that.
Now, vertex pipelines support
both Kubeflow pipelines
and also TensorFlow Extended.
Now, if you are already
using TensorFlow,
TensorFlow Extended is
a good choice for you.
It provides a rich
set of components
that helps you take
the TensorFlow code
and make it into an ML pipeline.
I did a video on TFX
not too long ago,
which I will include in
the description below.
Now, if you're not
using TensorFlow,
then use KFP, which is an
open-source machine learning
pipeline.
It offers a great
deal of flexibility.
It's easy to plug in code
from any ML framework,
including the normal frameworks
that aren't Python-based,
such as Apache MXNet.
Now, you might ask, why
do I need vertex pipelines
if I use Kubeflow
pipelines already today?
Now, the biggest reason
is that it is managed.
And because it is
managed, you don't
have to maintain or create
servers by yourself.
Now, when you're
using KFP, you need
to build, scale, and
maintain a Kubernetes cluster
all by yourself.
But with managed
pipelines, we don't
have to do any of that work.
It's all serverless.
OK, so in this video,
we got a quick overview
of MLOps workflow
and vertex pipelines.
What's next?
Let's take a look at
vertex pipelines demo
in our next video.
In the meantime, try out
the codelab linked below,
and subscribe to get notified
about the next video.